cientos de ciudades apagaron las luces
para unirse a la hora del planeta'
comenzando en asia los horizontes de
shanghai a hong kong y singapur se
oscurecieron a las 8 30 hora local-
hacer actividades como apagar las luces
apagar o todo te da un tiempo para hacer
una introspección básicamente para
entender dónde hemos estado hasta ahora
qué se debe hacer cuanto más se debía
hacer quizás sea el paso correcto hacia
la conciencia lo que comenzó en
australia hace 15 años ahora cobra
fuerza en 154 países con los monumentos
más emblemáticos del mundo sumidos en la
oscuridad para ayudar a crear conciencia
sobre el cambio climático y el medio
ambiente este año la hora del planeta
destacó el vínculo entre la destrucción
de la naturaleza y la creciente
incidencia de enfermedades como el cobo
y 19 dando el salto de los animales a
los humanos a medida que los símbolos
más representativos de europa se
oscurecieron incluida la torre eiffel en
parís el coliseo de roma y la plaza roja
de moscú un panda gigante la mascota del
fondo mundial para la naturaleza se
dispuso a activar el interruptor en la
puerta de brandeburgo de berlín con las
grandes reuniones descartadas para el
evento de este año se pidió a los
participantes que siguieran la acción en
línea y que empezaran a ver el planeta
bajo una nueva luz